depuis l'annnonce du confinement les
français rendent hommage tous les soirs
aux personnels de santé avec des
applaudissements
quant aux artistes privés de leur espace
de création ils ont trouvé par delà
leurs fenêtres
un nouvel auditoire luis carballo et
alexis compte faire du bruit
voilà le mot d'ordre de ces derniers
jours pour les français confinés chez
eux
des applaudissements concert improvisé
les initiatives populaires et artistique
se multiplient dans toute la france pour
soutenir le personnel médical
pour certains c'est aussi le moyen de
rompre l isolement des habitants et de
conserver du lien social à 20h pile
chaque soir depuis son balcon à lyon
arthur anima show d'une quinzaine de
minutes pour ses voisins
une idée qu'il a eue en regardant des
vidéos tournées en italie avant que la
politique dû rester chez vous le soit
instaurée en france
pour lui c'est une bonne occasion de
faire oublier aux gens les difficultés
liées au confinement pendant quelques
minutes
garder un contact humain également
[Musique]
d'informer soir ça a super bien pris
j'ai des voisins super sympa donc
surtout sortir leurs fenêtres à leur
balcon ou leur terrasse et puis voilà et
commence à danser et taper des mains
voilà avec les enfants et où je pense
que les gens ils sont beaucoup plus
décontractée depuis ce moment-là que je
reçois vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
messages de personnes qui sont seules ou
les enfants pour revoir avoir une
musique ou une dédicace et c'est donc
ils vont ils sont ils seront bien
contents les vents et je reconnais mon
message positif
à paris aussi musiciens et chanteurs se
sont spontanément liés à leurs fenêtres
ou leurs balcons pour partager leur
passion
collé à la capitale la ville de
montreuil a choisi de créer son propre
festival de musique au balcon une
initiative soutenue par le maire de la
ville patrice bessac sortir sur son
balcon mettre sa compétence de musiciens
son art son inspiration au service de la
communauté
je trouve ça très beau on a besoin de la
parole des artistes et des créateurs
à l'instar des italiens et des espagnols
les français se retrouvent en musique de
loin en attendant la fin du confinement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]